life is normal back to normal the new
normal as lockdown ease as many are
asking whether we'll return to the lives
we had back before coronavirus but what
if we didn't what if this were the
moment everything changed forever
a YouGov study for Sky News has found
that in the economic terms the majority
of Britons do not want a return to
normal when it comes to their jobs their
life stars the shape of the UK economy
57% want things to be significantly
different after this with only 25% once
in life to go back to how it was before
and for one former Chancellor change is
what's needed we've been talking you
know in terms of what do you do to get
the economy going well you could do
short-term things like that cut which I
did 10 years ago but perhaps some longer
things we've been talking about well how
do you get an economy was using less
carbon well the government has got the
spending power for research for
development that no other companies got
so you know that's an example of where
we could be changing things for the
better but the opportunities there the
big question is whether governments
around the world take that opportunity
now it's worth remembering this is
hardly the first crisis where people
have said life just can't return to
normal afterwards I mean think back over
the past decade you had the financial
crisis brexit the election of Donald
Trump and have allies really
fundamentally changed really and that's
the remaining question about
coronaviruses whether this is a sea
change or whether it's really just a
glimpse of an alternative economic
future and soon enough we just end up
forgetting at another former Chancellor
says that for all the dreaming of our
alternative futures a reversion to the
norm feels rather more likely I think
life may be more as it is now than
people imagine we hear a lot of talk
about social distancing becoming
semi-permanent well I think that's
frankly unreal it's completely against
human nature but he would also bankrupt
pulse waves of the economy and this this
country particularly the hospitality
industry which employs over 3 million
people more than the financial services
industry and if you introduce strict
social distancing there you would not
have the hospitality industry
back again and that ripples through the
whole economy yet might the ground be
shifting but we asked what the
government should do about all the money
borrowed during the recession the
biggest proportion 49 percent said it
shouldn't be paid off with the national
debt remaining permanently higher only
20 percent called for cuts in borrowing
even if that meant cutting back on
public services so more spending
permanently a bigger state or a return
to normal with the economy as with so
much these days the gap between possible
outcomes seems to be widening at Conway
Sky News